well it's interesting that the palace
have said they are appointing a
diversity
chief just weeks after the fallout over
the oprah
interview which of course saw the royal
family engulfed
in a very serious and unprecedented race
round now we learn that they are
in the process of hiring a chief of
staff my understanding is that this was
an appointment that was always going to
happen
it was something the royal family
thought was important as it
modernized and progress but it certainly
seems to have been
speed tracked post oprah and really
given paramount
importance now so we've seen that the
institution now
are reacting to that interview that
diversity is now very much
at the forefront of the palace and i
think the simple fact is that these
allegations of racism have stung they
have
hurt the royal family publicly and
privately
um as far as the royals are concerned
prince charles who has done so much to
promote
diversity and particularly in the uk and
around the commonwealth
and for prince william who is you know
championing an
anti-racism movement here in the uk
in sports particularly in football you
know these claims have
frankly been devastating and as far as
the royal family is concerned these
allegations are deeply damaging they are
very
upsetting i think we saw that very much
with prince william responding
when asked if the royal family was
racist and he said this is
very much not a racist family i think
you're now going to see even more
evidence of them really
proving just that i'm sure that megan
and harry would very much want to be
involved with discussions about how the
palace might become a more diverse
workplace but the feeling i get is this
is very much handled
in-house this is being taken care of by
courtiers with the oversight of the
queen and members of the royal family
but
essentially this is an in palace
operation and i think it's quite telling
that megan and harry haven't been
invited to be part of the investigation
into the bullying claims
against megan they're being kept quite
deliberately distant from that
and i would expect that it will be very
much the same with this
whole movement towards a more diverse
working operation at buckingham palace
the couple have cut their ties with the
palace
with the courtiers there's really no
reason for them to be a part of these
discussions but i think the point is
the palace have heard what the couple
have to say they have listened
and now measures being put in place to
act on some of those challenges